a todos como están
sawyer nan barragán h de magia y estoy
muy feliz estar acá soy mercador hui
publicista tengo 22 años y lo más
importante es que soy vago profesional
cuando digo esto todos me preguntan cómo
es que soy mago profesional cómo llega
alguien a ser mago que es la magia y
como estoy aquí siendo mago la primera
vez que y magia tenía cuatro años una
tía llego a casa de mis abuelos y mejor
que debe enseñar algo nuevo algo
diferente toma una moneda la pone en su
mano
la soplaba y desaparecía o sea la moneda
no emitía
y cuando vi esto me encantó y dije
quiero aprender a hacer esto cómo se
hace
y lo mejor fue que la misma moneda
aparecía a metros de mí en una ventana
yo no sabía qué había pasado con el
tiempo poco a poco aprendí a ser más
magia hacía cosas fáciles y quiero
enseñarles un ejemplo de cómo es la
magia que es lo que viví y qué es lo que
sentí ese día yo a diferencia de mi tía
voy a utilizar una tela para que todos
lo puedan ver y enseñaba la mano la mano
vacía una tela la ponía en su mano y
enseñaba la otra mano vacía entre la
tenía en la mano poco a poco toda la
tela hay que soplar y la tela desaparece
la mejor parte es cuando la tela
regresa yo cuando vi eso aplaude
sí
[Aplausos]
imagínense no todos los días viendo una
tierra
cuando vi eso quise hacer magia empecé a
hacer magia y cuando hago magia aparte
de la historia que les conté los que
todos me preguntan lo que todo lo que
quieren saber es que es la magia de
verdad existe es bueno es malo brujería
pacto que es la magia y yo quiero
enseñarles un concepto que en contra de
la magia
es el concierto que aparece en internet
acerca de la magia dice que son trucos
habilidades y juegos de mano para
aparecer desaparecer cosas aparecen un
elefante cortar alguien a la mitad y
todo esto es un concepto del ilusionismo
como arte a lo que me dedico eso es la
magia como ilusionismo con el tiempo me
dado cuenta que la magia tiene otro
concepto
la magia es lo más parecido a un
sentimiento como por ejemplo cuando
estás feliz y siente felicidad o te
enojas sientes ese enojo dentro de ti
cuando sientes magia es esto
la magia es el conjunto de conocimientos
y prácticas con los que se pretende
conseguir cosas extraordinarias cuando
sientes magia sientes que todo es
posible
otros conjuntos de conocimientos
prácticas y habilidades puedes lograr
cosas que nunca imaginaste cuando vives
esa magia las sientes la puedes
transmitir a los demás y que ellos la
vivan junto contigo
este soy yo
cuando empecé a hacer magia en eventos
yo nunca había hecho magia para más de
tres personas cuando aprendí a hacer
magia me especialicé en magia de cerca
más que con monedas con ligas con cartas
es magia close of a 11 magia de cerca
cuando un día sale al parque hacer magia
un hobby algo que hacía siempre me
encontré una persona que le gustó mucho
lo que hice a él le hice algo con cartas
y me dijo que me quiere invitar a formar
parte de lo que él vendía para las
fiestas de niños para los eventos que
hacía yo nunca había participado en nada
de esto y me dijo que sí de qué manera
podía vender mi show que quería un show
para 100 personas para mañana como lo
haces yo le dije no no o sea yo hago
magia de mes en mes ahí no pueden ver
todos porque yo no sé hacer eso yo lo
que quería era meter la idea de que mi
magia era única y especial porque era
diferente normalmente es un mago arriba
de un escenario y hace cosas
para todos cuando yo me acercaba a las
mesas era algo diferente guau el mago
está aquí pero me di cuenta con el
tiempo que eso no era que yo me
especializada en eso y que era lo más
interesante de ver era de verdad que
estaba en una zona de confort que no
quería dejar era aprender cosas nuevas
era
aventarme a un público que antes había
hecho pero no haciendo magia la magia de
cerca ya sabía cuáles eran mis ángulos
que tenía que hacer que no tenía que
hacer que tenía que decir a una mujer
que tenía que decir un nombre que tenía
que hacer un niño ya sabía todo
y me arriesgue y este es uno de los
shows que tuve al principio y aquí tengo
algo que les quiero mostrar
esto es lo primero que metí a mi show de
magia
luego para adultos y luego para niños es
un libro mágico para colorear
aquí dice magic calling book que
significa
la magia cuando el mago colorea y está
bien guapo hd magia
cuando lo vi la primera vez yo no sabía
que tenía tiene algo muy raro este libro
para colorear no tenía dibujos para
colorear era un libro totalmente
distinto a lo que es un libro para
colorear
tenía unas instrucciones en una hojita
decía que este libro se podía colocar
con una palabra mágica
me di cuenta que las palabras mágicas no
son las que todos sabemos todos
conocíamos abracadabra viví divabe
dibujo en los shows me han dicho a veces
que las balas mágicas son por favor y
gracias ven mucho barniz películas de
niños aunque eso me gusta porque es
verdad una palabra mágica se vuelve
mágica cuando crees en ella algo cuando
crees en ello se vuelve mágico
por ejemplo
tú el de rayas en el cual es su nombre
entonces no es cierto jorge quiero que
una palabra mágica que se tenga la mente
cualquier palabra que te guste lo que
sea la vas a decir ahorita
deseo que deseas
o es la palabra ok deseo es la palabra a
la cuenta de tres no sólo tú sino todos
van a ayudar a jorge a creer en la
palabra que quiere y la magia va a pasar
la palabra es deseo yo voy a decir uno
dos tres y cuando diga tres
que van a decir deseo
1 2 3
qué bonito
y ahora el libro empieza a tener dibujos
todos las páginas para colorear deseo
bien un aplauso para él
no no
el siguiente paso que tiene las
instrucciones era que el niño
cumpleañero o la persona más importante
especial de ese día tenía que elegir un
dibujo de sus para colorear por ejemplo
el canguro el mono el elefante los o el
caballo habían muchos si yo pregunté qué
dibujo quieren que se colores
lo hice mal la primera vez que lo hacía
porque yo tenía que decir
específicamente a alguien por ejemplo a
él qué dibujo quieres como lo dije a
todos todos hicieron dibujos diferentes
olvídenlo pero pasó algo que yo no sabía
cómo había pasado porque la magia a
veces yo no sé cómo pasa pero pasa y se
siente vieron varios dibujos los los
animales lo vieron más o menos cuál
viste tú
si tus ojos o un oso caballo como no hay
de todos a la cuenta de tres web voy a
hacer así y cuando yo haga así todos
dicen los animales animal que quieran
van a decir diferentes todos les gusta
diferentes y a ver qué tal qué tal se
lee la magia pasa ok están listos si no
salen no soy yo eso ustedes no creen
tienen que creer imagínense lo una dos
tres
y ahora todos los dibujos empiezan a
estar
coloreados
y así me habla gente
todos los mismos
quiere decir que creer es lo más
importante porque cuando alguien cree en
algo ustedes no lo pudieron ver pero
intento de algún día díganle alguien que
diga algo lo que sea deseo si yo te digo
cuando te dije que dijeras la palabra
deseo este deseo cuando te dije cree en
la palabra y dile asiste cara así como
el que todavía algo 70 todos hicieron
así de dieron todo y ustedes para que
esa palabra de verdad se sintiera no
fuera una palabra cualquiera hay una
frase que me gusta mucho que dice que
sólo aquellos que creen en la magia
estarán destinados a encontrarla
quiero que hagamos un pequeño ejercicio
y cuando yo cuente 3 chasqueó los dedos
y todos cierran los ojos ok 123 duerman
siempre los ojos cerrados cerrados
cerrados error respiren una vez
o sea que en el aire
quiero que frente a ustedes se imaginan
que tienen un sombrero de magos todos
vamos a hacer vamos a abrir al principio
les dije que todos podíamos ser magos
cada quien tiene lo necesario para ser
mago para tener más que transmitir la
frente ustedes hay un sombrero un
sombrero de mago que se acaban de quitar
ya lo pusieron frente a ustedes
normalmente podría ser un conejo unas
palomas flores algo que un mago puede
aparecer pero quiero que hay dentro se
imaginen que está su mayor deseo lo que
más quieran el truco de magia que
necesiten lograr algo que quieran lograr
y de verdad lo quieran en su mano
derecha o la mano izquierda como quieran
van a tener una varita mágica
esa manita mágica le van a pasar sobre
el sombrero
y se van a comprometer con eso que
quieren lograr van a dar todo de ustedes
para lograrlo cuando cuente 3 pasen la
varita mágica sobre el sombrero abran
los ojos y a partir de ese momento viven
la magia de lo que quieren lograr 1 2 3
para abrir sus ojos
en mi mente nunca imaginé que todos
fueran a ser así cuando lo estaba
pensando pero fue muy bonito
todos son magos a partir de ahora
yo creía en mí
creía en mí
y confía en mí eso es creer creer en las
posibilidades de una persona o cosa
cuando crees sabes que tienes
posibilidades y lo puedes lograr
creí y pasó de estar en eventos para 11
personas a estar con más de 3000
personas en un escenario
yo nunca imaginé estar así tal vez creer
en ti es difícil
y creer en los demás igual hacer que los
demás crean en ti
no importa a veces todos creen que para
que hacer creer a los demás que voy a
lograr algo si yo lo logro y sé que soy
feliz con ello pues no pasa nada pero
cuando crees en ti y lo demuestras de
los demás ellos empiezan a creer en
ellos y logran cosas también
es difícil y voy a decir que me crean
con esto puede que sepan cómo se hace
pero si hago que crean lo van a poder
ver aquí tengo dibujado un punto lo ven
de este lado tengo dibujado opuestos
cuatro puntos del otro lo tengo por
estos tres puntos y acá tengo seis
y yo sé cómo pasa es imposible en una
hoja no puede haber un punto cuatro
puntos tres puntos y seis puntos porque
una hoja suelta de dos lados les voy a
enseñar cómo es agarran un papel un
cartón una hoja lo que sea y de un lado
le van a dibujar un punto del otro lado
le ponen cuatro puntos pero otro lado le
pueden tres puntos y los seis puntos
pero la magia y si lo quieren puede
pasar les voy a enseñar de verdad cómo
es si yo hago así tapó y pareciera que
hay un punto cartas y todas las ideas y
hacia el ratón punto cuatro pero no de
verdad un punto tres puntos apuntó tres
puntos
4 puntos 6 puntos 4 puntos
tapen aquí si lo llegan a hacer porque 4
puntos
hay que hacer
si ustedes cuando creen que yo hago así
pareciera que hay algo así 4 parece que
3 cuando empiezan a creer en lo que les
digo empiezan a verlo esa es la cosa
es que ya creyeron
cuando creen que hay que hay tres hay
tres yo hago así y pareciera que hay
seis si empiezan a creerlo lo siguen
viendo es
es la magia ni idea
lo interesante es que cuando aquí hay 3
366 ya todos creen que si no cuando no
saben cómo pasa es cuando aquí hay 7
cuando todos me aplauden es cuando aquí
hay tres y atrás había siete pero
aplauden cuando hay ocho
sí
[Aplausos]
cuando logras algo pareciera cuestión de
suerte a mí me ha tocado mucho que me
dicen oye qué suerte que estás en este
evento qué suerte que lograste esto qué
suerte que tienes likes qué suerte que
te siguen qué suerte que yo creo que la
suerte es agarrar un dado tirarlo y que
te caiga el número que querías
la suerte tiene una fórmula y es esta la
fórmula de la suerte es cuando tu
preparación y la oportunidad se
encuentran y justo ahí es tu suerte yo
tengo más de 13 años preparándome como
mago amando lo que hago y
comprometiéndome a siempre ser mejor a
lograr cosas la oportunidad se ha dado
cuando estaba en el parque en una plaza
en un restaurante en cualquier lugar
haciendo magia sorprendiendo a los demás
y buscando mis metas ahí es cuando la
suerte me ha alcanzado
el concepto de la magia dice que es el
conjunto de prácticas conocimientos
habilidades quiere decir que es
prácticas conocimientos muchos plural no
solamente un conocimiento una práctica
te puede ayudar yo aparte de mago les
dije soy mercadólogo combine las dos
cosas que hago y he logrado mucho más
con la mercadotecnia y publicidad creé
mi imagen mi marca mi logo mi eslogan
vídeos los edite los hubiera redes los
promocione
contacte con muchas personas para
empezar a crecer así es podido estar en
teatros en muchos más eventos con plazas
trabajar con restaurantes y marcas he
trabajado con marcas combinando la magia
y la publicidad creó trucos de magia
para presentar algún producto o algún
mensaje que quieran dar a conocer al
público y ahí es cuando yo creo en mí
quiero que todos vivamos la magia
ahorita y no ha acabado regresamos
quiero que vivamos la magia y cuando
empezaron cuando entramos les dieron
cuatro tarjetas solo tienen
yo aquí tengo las mías todas tienen una
ley y está le quitan la legal
si en la tiran y desaparece
esos cuatro tarjetitas de un lado tienen
y luego hb magia del otro lado tienen
palabras por ejemplo amor compromiso té
de c's y magia cuatro palabras
diferentes
quiero que viva cada uno en sus lugares
la magia
tienen que seguir paso a paso lo que les
digo para que puedan hacerlo
estas cuatro cartas todas tienen que
estar viendo hacia el mismo lugar
hacia acá
pero todas
las palabras van a estar viendo hacia
abajo
y el logo viendo hacia ustedes
imagínense como si me estuvieran
enseñando las palabras a mí
así
agarradas de esta manera
en las palabras hacia abajo
lo que van a hacer es muy importante
van a cortar por la mitad las cuatro
cartas
no es tan difícil por la mitad
ahora se dividió y tal vez no hay cuatro
cartas si no hay 84 de este lado y 4 de
este lado
ustedes van a elegir si quieren poner la
parte derecha sobre la izquierda o la
parte izquierda sobre la derecha como
quieran yo voy a poner la derecha de la
izquierda justo así ahora hay un
montoncito de más cartas
el siguiente paso es que tomen las tres
primeras de arriba una dos y tres las
tres de arriba para que se empiecen a
mezclar esas tres las van a poner en
medio en medio normal hasta arriba y las
pongan abajo póngalas en medio para que
se empiecen a mezclar todas
en medio no arriba ni abajo en medio
para que siga una mezcla la carta que
tienen hasta arriba quiero que la pongan
en su bolsa cerca de ustedes en algún
lugar donde la puedan agarrar y sea
fácil para ustedes yo le voy a poner
aquí abajo ahí que quede mientras para
que todos la puedan ver ese de ahí la
tienen ahora el siguiente es lo que
ustedes quieran pueden agarrar una dos o
tres de arriba como quieran puede ser
una de arriba dos de arriba o tres de
arriba yo voy a agarrar solamente una y
dos pueden agarrar solo una dos o tres
ya que las tienen en esta mano las
vuelven a poner en medio no arriba ni
abajo en medio para que se sigan
mezclando las cartas
todo se está haciendo una mezcla que
nadie ninguno va a tener lo mismo y cada
quien está siendo diferente la carta que
tienen hasta arriba la van a cambiar con
la persona de al lado o con quien
quieran pueden cambiarla para que
todavía se vuelva una mezcla entre todos
nosotros y cada quien tenga un pedazo
diferente esa que les acaban de dar
la vuelven en medio también que se
pierda en medio de arriba en abajo en
medio para que se ha mezclado
perfectamente ya está listo
segurísimos
ahora vamos a seguir esos pasos una
carta cuando yo les diga se va a poner
abajo la que sigue la vamos a tirar
hacia arriba y la carta que sigue se va
a poner abajo la que sigue se va a tirar
vamos a ir haciendo hasta que nos queden
solamente la mitad de una cuando la
pongamos abajo vamos a decir
ted y cuando la siguiente la tiremos
vamos a decir magia ok empezamos con la
primera
la siguiente magia
usted
magia
magia tiene solamente una carta en la
mano tienen una desde el principio si
vivieron la magia y la pasaron le
ocurrió quiere decir que la misma
palabra es y complementa la otra mitad
enseñan todos que la palabra es
justamente la carta que tienen
[Aplausos]
[Música]
eso es magia para todos menos para quien
va a barrer
estoy seguro y tal vez
tal vez a todos todavía nos falta mucho
por aprender por hacer y por lograr
así que siempre recuerden
creer en ustedes
hagan más de lo que aman y siempre
vivan su magia muchas gracias de verdad
va a regar hasta la próxima
[Aplausos]